hello I'm Joe Haley I'm from st. Cloud
State University in st. Cloud Minnesota
happy to be here at the Wolfram tech
conference 2016 my presentation is about
using directional bit sequences to
display the property and liability
underwriting cycle as an algorithmic
process thank you I'm talking about the
underwrite property liability under iron
cycle property and liability under and
psychical is simply a profit cycle for
the underwriting activities in the
property and liability industry you can
see I got the data there from 1932
202,000 it's kind of old but I had some
count annuity problems I didn't want to
take time to mess with so I stuck with
the 1932 2000 underwriting cycle or
profit cycle for property my ability
just deals with their profits on their
underwriting activities they sell
policies they collect premiums and they
pay losses and that's known as there are
underrated activities the graph shows
the underwriting margin so margin of
five means for every dollar and premium
you pay to 95 cents and losses and
expenses and on that graph so you made a
nickel for every dollar of premium the
aggregate you can see it in the graph
here the the aggregate profits are
characterized by your regular
fluctuations I want to emphasize your
regular because there are some people in
the insurance area that in the academia
that trying to get rid of the word cycle
because it's not regular you know it's
not like three years down three years up
or whatever I don't I don't get caught
up in those conversations everybody I
know in the industry calls it a cycle
and the cycle fluctuates hard market and
soft market hard market gets its name
because it's hard or difficult to get
coverage rising price
is restrictive underwriting restrictive
underwriting just means insurance
companies are more careful about who
they sell a policy to who they led into
their risk pool and and then soft
markets the other way around falling
prices liberal underwrite and they'll
let anybody into the risk pool they'll
they'll sell their policies to anyone
we're not to anyone but they're more
easily convinced to sell one
theoretically profits should behave more
random I mean this is why the
underwriting cycle becomes of interest
because theoretically the profits should
behave more randomly because the losses
are very random losses are very random
but you can see that there is a cycle
there so what I did is I created a
simulation and then I wont needed to
figure out if my simulation was sort of
accurate and I mean is it is it
representative of the real of what what
really happens so some important
features only pure premium is modelled
pure premium is just the dollars that
the insurance company collects to pay
losses a premium is made up of multiple
parts it's a pure premium the expected
losses and then it's got expense loads
and risk loads on it okay i'm ignoring
the expense loads and the risk loads so
for me equilibrium would be profit
margin of zero you collect just enough
lost dollars to pay for losses you
collect just enough premium to pay for
losses there would be a risk load on top
of that that turns into profit but I'm
not doing that my simulations
agent-based individual insurers
following a pricing rule separately as
you'll see I've got 75 insurance
companies in my simulation each of them
are acting on their own they're all
following the same pricing rule but they
all have their own circumstances losses
in and and target capital structure
capital structure is just the mix of
equity and debt and each company has a
targeted capital structure example would
be a forty percent equity sixty percent
debt the only debt that my insurance
companies have our losses so they sell a
policy they immediately create a
contingent liability of having to pay a
loss and so in in the 40 60 structure
you start off they got two million
dollars in equity so that means you're
going to sell three million dollars in
policies because where the goal is to
break even collect just enough money to
pay losses so you'll sell three million
dollars in premium and have a matching
three million and expected losses so
you've got it two million and equity
three million debt the insurance is
mandatory and the industry faces a
downward sloping demand curve I just
kind of got rather than stick the
formula up there for the demand curve I
just stuck these two graphs the one on
the Left shows a wide range of prices
552 35 375 and so the curt the demand
curve is is convex and the other panel b
has a narrow range of prices 50 to 75 so
the curve which appears quite linear one
thing with to keep in mind with the
demand demand curve every insurance
company gets at least a customer at
least at least a small batch of
customers so even if some insurance
company charges a really high price that
they'll still get a tiny tiny part of
the market which isn't that weird I mean
companies will start charging higher
prices and their customers are loyal
so what happens with dissimulation what
I forgot forgot I forgot I need to go
talk about the pricing rule this is why
I call it an algorithmic process it's
probably about the most simplest version
of an algorithmic process you might have
seen it's just they charge a premium
based on three things expected losses
last year's surplus which is the
insurance word for equity and last
year's size of risk pool which is a
number of customers the expected losses
is a constant I say approximately 3000
123 because that constant actually
changes from simulation to simulation
but but when I run a simulation expected
losses is determined in the beginning
and then it's constant throughout last
year's surplus is just the equity the
plasters equity and then size of risk
pulls a number of customers you can see
the pricing rule don't need to go
through that a whole lot but you can see
it's simple it's pretty simple and they
are there that's the target target
capital structure surplus over assets
how many of your assets are you holding
as equity what proportion premiums are
collected at the beginning of the year
losses at the end so there's actually a
two-year lag because you have the
surplus from t minus one feeds into the
price right now and then losses don't
get paid until the end of the year so
it's actually a two-year leg to your leg
by itself kind of explains why you get a
cycle instead of just randomness with
the losses and losses are simulated
using skew normal actually it's mixed
with skew normal mixed with binomial so
you wind up with a big list of mostly
zeros and then like five five percent
losses and that's how those insurance
companies on the commercials claim to
have a ninety-five percent customer
approval because 95 so the customers
don't have any claims don't have any
lost as I do is not
mad and they'll they'll approve what
you're doing okay results 75 and I just
call this simulation X will show some
others but 75 companies for 200 years
you can see the graph on the left that
is the aggregate underwriting cycle
simulated a great under and cycle the
one we saw before was the real one and
you can see that it's pretty regular
kind of cycle if you count trough to
trough or peak to peak you usually get
six but not always every company starts
off in equilibrium what I do is I give
every cut company a hundred thousand
customers and then and then they know
their expected loss and then I just give
them a give them a surplus that'll match
their equilibrium that'll match their
target you can see that the average loss
print shirt is on the other one and
that's very random and it's not cyclical
at all so why am i doing all this I
generated the simulated cycle and I
wanted to compare it to the actual and I
was thinking well if it matches up with
the actual then I can say my rule-based
price you know my price rule is sort of
accurate excuse me but if I do a usual
comparison of this there's 200 years in
the other one is 71 years if I do a
usual comparison they're nothing
compared doesn't match up at all there's
no correlation there no nothing no leg
correlations no nothing so then I
thought well maybe I'll compare them and
this was my the promo for the for this
conference said if you think you did
something clever okay so this is my
clever part I compared these time series
with what's called direct what are
called directional bit sequences the
idea I got the idea from an article by a
gentleman named Hector Z know who I
believe what has worked or does work
with wolfram Hector's enel and
a guy named Ella hey he they do
something very different from what i'm
doing but but they didn't create this
directional bit string which is what
gave me the idea so I do i do a fort or
at least what it's reported here is a
four topple directional bit sequence
between the actual under any margin and
the simulate simulated entry margin one
is up to is down or I mean one is up
zero is down and so on my graph here so
you got four top we've got four bits in
the string and so there's 16 possible
possibilities Oh point one is 1111 which
is up up up up and then 0 point 16 is
down down down down if you look at the
graph you can see that up up up up never
happened at all with the actual data the
solid line represents the actual data of
the dash line is the simulated data the
graph also is discrete graph but I
connected the lines to make it look
prettier and annoying that you can see
they match up pretty well the the for
couple directional bit string from the
actual data and the simulated data match
up quite well I did two tupple three
four five and six and they all pretty
much the same I disliked the four and
you can see a correlation point nine and
so now I'm saying they have a similar
they have similar structures here that
their actual data and the simulated data
have a similar structure with regards to
the direction of their movement and and
which is important because I never
mentioned when you when you looked at
that simulated when you looked at the
simulated bit string or I mean the
simulated under right margin it did tend
to equilibrium it was it was bouncing
around zero which was equilibrium the
real the real industry I've done some
other research the real industry people
agree pursues equilibrium so I'm saying
that these these two time series pursue
equilibrium
in the direction of their movement what
about some other simulations well quick
look at four others have done dozens and
they all look the same correlations a
little bit different that one's got a
correlation of 0 point 8 6 it's real
unusual to get anything for me to get
anything under point 8.5 I'm sorry under
point eight five it's real unusual to
get a negative point paid five so the
simulation is generating the this time
series that matches matches the the real
world so so I'm saying that the
direction of the changes are the same
okay well what about what about the way
that the time series are distributed
around equilibrium so what I want to do
is look at the shape of the of the
simulated time series you can see the
simulation X and you look at that by
itself and it didn't doesn't matter too
much I mean you can see what it looks
like but how about those other four well
as other for simulations or have way
different shapes and and and so what I'm
concluding here and you can see in the
next slide is the behavior around
equilibrium is very different there's no
consistency to it which of course as
trained as an economist I would tell my
honest friends this all the time and
they would know it wouldn't always
believed me but but you know pursuing
equilibrium in the 1970s no matter what
you're talking about is different than
pursuing equilibrium in the 1980s and
1990s in the 1930s I mean the market is
always going to equilibrium but if it
goes fast or slow yeah that there's so
many factors that go into it and and so
then so I'm saying well now my simulated
data matches the actual but but I'm
going to separate the notion of a
probability distribution that governs
the data some initials so some initial
conclusions you have this common
structure common structure so is the
underwriting cycle following a
rule-based process
we're continuously seeking equilibrium
and then number for their the usual
notion of a continuous probability
distribution being the basis of a data
generating process on the time services
is relaxed that's a nice way of saying
okay let's forget about it and the last
one the actual underwriting cycle we
observe you know because we ran the
simulation over and over and we observe
different things different distributions
about equilibrium the actual
underwriting cycle we observe is just
one of many many possibilities I joke
with my students you know Yolo you only
live once you know that that path that
you see that's just what what you just
happen to see there's like a thousand or
a million or infinite possibilities that
could happen so I like this conclusion i
thought well can I move forward can I
can I look at other parts of the
simulation and see if it means anything
or if I just get something goofy okay
first I looked at companies the
individual companies how do they behave
with regards the industry in economics
for a while went through this
representative agent stuff that I didn't
like but anyway can see here there's
four companies that I just picked off
one on the upper left is pretty
correlated with the industry the one on
the bottom on the left is negatively
correlated with the industry and then
the 10 and the other ones in between and
so since since we have an agent-based
model and what we have is that we have
micro to sit micro economic decisions
that can't be deduced from macroeconomic
right we can watch the results for the
industry but the individual companies
are all doing their own thing okay
they're all following that pricing rule
but they all have their own
circumstances they are they are there
you know their own at random losses
their own target capital structures and
so I kind of I asked the question and
then my answer is yeah sort of but ask
the questions is evidence of emergence
and I would say yeah sort of you got the
individual companies doing their own
thing and then you got this aggregate
behavior that makes it look like the
companies are all work maybe all working
together kind of a classic bird flocking
idea and importance there is the
downward downward sloping demand curve
puts discipline on the behavior okay now
something else to look at volatility
this is an aggregate margin this is not
simulation X I picked this simulation
because right around T equals 125 the
market becomes more volatile I mean you
can see it but also if you look closer
or if you do some work if I do more
calculations the correlation across the
company's goes up in periods of
volatility well that has some you can
bet has tamika not intuitive sense to it
it periods of volatility companies start
behaving together and then property and
liability industry they'll talk about
the race to the bottom some company will
start cutting prices others one others
will start following it and and before
long their way low their way lower than
they need to be and then they all raised
their prices together and and and then
they get accused of collusion that
happened in the 80s and it happened in
the 40s to i believe so anyway paired
the volatility the companies start start
behaving together which has some
intuitive sense to it okay now i also
decided to look again i'm looking at the
simulation trying to see if there's
other pieces that make sense i like the
directional bit sequences and the move
the simulation pursuing equilibrium like
the
aggregate so what I did was I ran some
additional simulations size 15 35 55 and
75 companies thank you you can see well
first off you can see that when the
standard deviation is greater in general
when the standard deviation is greater
the average correlation across companies
now that what's being courted what I'm
looking at here is the underwriting
margin the profitability so when the
standard deviation is greater the
company's profits are more correlated
the companies are moving together as
profits directly related to a price but
also there's the tendency for industry
with smaller company smaller a number of
companies to be more volatile and more
correlated then you know because up here
and it got 15 15 15 15 15 15 35 I think
this is a 35 35 35 and then down here
we've got a lot of 75 s and 55 s it's
not perfect you can see a 75 here and a
55 but how do i think the industries
with the smaller number of companies
tend to be more correlated and more
volatile well that that has some
intuitive sense with it as well the
company with an industry this fewer
number of companies is less competitive
less competitive you can if you guys
have a couple of companies start moving
one way than then everybody sort of
follows in terms of price so
here's a CDF of the simulation 75
comments going to change as soon as it
runs through but it takes a while 75
companies 200 years you can see it's a
volatility you can see the bit strings
lineup I also on here that orange line
that's just random data to show that the
bits the bid strings that are matching
are separate or distinct from just
random data and the court of the
correlation of the bit strings is point
88 correlation across companies is point
32 what just changed on me correlation
across companies was point 32 which was
a little bit high for 75 let's see what
we get here this was another 75
companies directional bit strings again
they match up almost all the time
correlation the bit strings point 88
correlation across companies point 26
that's still that well that's probably
just slightly higher than typical these
two numbers this one here the weighted
average of underwriting margin should be
zero which it is this needs to be zero
to just kind of as checks as two things
going up going okay average Android
margin should be zero mean the
industry's in pursuing equilibrium all
the time and there shouldn't be any
correlation of losses across the
industry let's do a 15 company that
shouldn't take too long unless you're
really tired then it seems like fun here
we go now this one is very volatile
looks very volatile it's all the way up
to five percent the directional bit
sequences again matchup as almost always
correlation of the bit strings point
eight eight seems to be hitting point
eight eight all the time but here with
the 15 companies look at the correlation
across companies point seven eight that
market with just a few company
companies small number of companies
became very volatile everybody's
behaving together and and and we have
very correlated activity so I know you
want to go to the reception so I won't
do that CDF again that's nice and slow
family conclusions again I say that then
underwriting cycle can be modeled as an
algorithmic process which means that we
don't have this data generating function
for the time series right equilibrium
has a gravity like pull on the economic
activity which we always hope for Ithaka
economics movement towards but the
movement towards equilibrium isn't
uniform or symmetrical through time some
some deviations are adjusted to very
quickly somewhere adjusted very slowly
when it comes to economics there's
always a thousand factors you can't even
figure out that influence these things
and so and so I'm really just trying to
her trying to say that will analyze
analyze the changes separate from the
magnitude of the changes and there's no
data generating process the companies
follow this rule about pricing and and
and so the next step I haven't really
done a whole lot with it the next step
then would be the study that just the
changes the magnitude of the changes
around the around equilibrium the speed
at which they just but but how that
that's kind of random I would use the
word phrase stochastic volatility but
I'm starting to be outside my outside my
skills
each company following the price rule
industries I operate along the demand
curve a type of emergence occurs company
activities more correlated during
periods of volatility we all kind of
learn that the financial crisis of 2008
everybody started doing the same thing
and an industry with fewer companies
prone to more volatility less
competitive that that's a kind of a
standard economic conclusion as well